joining us now former a CDC director dr.
Tom Frieden dr. I want to start with the
spread of the virus these past two weeks
there was on Friday more than 45,000 new
cases a new single day high for our
country and thirteen states at record
highs for their seven-day average new
cases but vice president pence said this
we have made a truly remarkable progress
in moving our nation forward we've all
seen the encouraging news as we open up
America again doctor are we making truly
remarkable progress and is that the
right message to be sending to the
nation at this moment well there's no
doubt we're doing more testing our
hospitals are better prepared but
there's also no doubt that the virus has
the upper hand this virus is not going
to go away on its own we have to stop it
and only we can do that by working
together we're all sick and tired of
staying home but you know what the virus
is not tired of making us sick and what
we're seeing particularly in southern
states but in most parts of the u.s. is
the virus increasing and in some states
increasing explosively let me drill down
on that how do you explain the new surge
in cases especially in the south and the
west did some states in those regions
did they open up too soon
reopen too soon and without enough
restrictions Chris as I said to you six
weeks ago today this is going to
backfire we're moving too fast if you
open when cases are still increasing as
many states did it's like leaning into a
left hook you're going to get hit hard
and that's what's happening when we see
Arizona Texas Florida South Carolina
they are currently in a rapid upswing
and
sad to say this is going to continue to
get worse for weeks because the physical
distance thing that they're implementing
now will only take effect you don't see
it for another few weeks so we're going
to see a few more weeks of increases in
all likelihood in several states now
there's some comfort in the fact that
it's younger people but what starts in
the young doesn't stay in the young
younger people have parents uncles
nephews that go out to places to buy
food and there we're going to see
increasing spread that's why the three
WS are so important wear a mask wash
your hands or use sanitizer and watch
your distance there's something everyone
can do we are really all in this
together and if we work together we can
help control the virus and get our
economy back Public Health and health
issues are not getting in the way of our
recovery
they are the route to our recovery
doctor one of the arguments you hear is
that the reason we're seeing a surge in
new cases is because we're seeing a
surge in more testing here's President
Trump on that this week we have more
cases because we do the greatest testing
if we didn't do testing would have no
cases is this surge a function of more
testing or is it a reflection of the
fact that the virus is actually
spreading as a doctor a scientist an
epidemiologist I can tell you with 100%
certainty that in most states where
you're seeing an increase it is a real
increase it is not more tests it is more
spread of the virus and the one number
to look at that's very important is the
percent of tests that's positive the
number of cases that can vary some
because we're only diagnosing oh 10 20 %
of all cases so the numbers you're
seeing are just a reflection of tip of
the iceberg of even more spread but
where the numbers are increasing you've
got Arizona with new
one out of four tests positive at the
same time you're increasing the number
of tests I can tell you for at with
absolute certainty that's explosive
spread of coronavirus while we're seeing
the number of cases explodes up sixty
five percent in the last two weeks we're
seeing the number of deaths actually
dropped twenty-seven percent how do you
explain that there are a few things
going on
first off deaths will lag cases by about
a month takes some time for someone to
feel sick get hospitalized and
unfortunately die second the cases do
appear to be in younger people now and
the death rate is far far far lower in
younger people than older but as I said
earlier which starts in young adults
doesn't stay in young adults so there
may be a lag until we see cases it's
possible that older people are shielding
themselves more and we're also getting
better at caring for the disease in
hospitals so the explosive spread isn't
being followed
yet by an explosive increase in deaths
but what we are seeing in some states
already is a big increase in intensive
care unit admissions and that's a sign
that this is not benign this is going to
result in more deaths we estimate in the
next month we'll see at least 15,000
were deaths in the u.s. meanwhile this
has all become even more of a political
issue as everything seems to be in this
country seventy six percent of Democrats
say that they wear a mask all or most of
the time as compared to 53 percent of
Republicans and this week 3,000 young
supporters of the president packed a
church in Arizona as you can see on the
screen here almost none of them wearing
Mouse here is vice president pence the
freedom of speech and the right to
peaceably assemble is enshrined in the
Constitution in the United States and
even in a health crisis the American
people don't forfeit our constitutional
rights I'm asking you this as the former
head of the CDC one of the leading
public health experts in the country as
a matter of
public health not a matter of
constitutional law what do you think
when you see hundreds thousands of
people close together indoors not
wearing masks the science is clear more
people with less ventilation indoors
with a high rate of coronavirus not
wearing masks that is a formula for
explosive spread of the virus finally
President Trump continues to say that
we're going to see a vaccine his words
very soon perhaps by before the end of
the year what is the likelihood of that
give us a reality check and when we can
really begin to think about a vaccine
although we're seeing really encouraging
progress there's no evidence that people
do get immunity it may be protective
there are more than a hundred vaccine
candidates being evaluated some of them
are looking good in some preliminary
studies it's really hard to develop a
vaccine because you have to make sure
it's safe
there's already too much suspicion about
vaccines we can't cut any corners we
have to make sure it's safe it's
effective figure out the right dose
decide who's going to get it first
develop it manufacture large quantities
get it out there set up systems to track
for bad reactions this is not a quick
fix it's really important to do it's the
single most important thing we can do to
fight corona virus and that's why it's
so important we have to do it carefully
can't cut any corners may have it next
year but what having it means me is a
little different it means that people
are going to start to have availability
for health care workers for example but
we have to make sure it's safe and
effective before we put it into people's
arms
dr. Freiden thank you thanks for your
time always good to talk with you sir